uh i've been remiss i haven't done any
videos here
we're leaving israel today heading off
to greece
uh so i wanted sort of to update my
viewers i'm standing in a an area called
sarona which is a an oasis of quiet
here in a bustling city tel aviv
amazing skyscrapers traffic
until all hours of the evening from what
i can tell
my wife and i have had a very
interesting time uh
strolling through the city full of cafes
and restaurants on the beach down to
jaffa which is the old
arab city we yesterday we rented a car
the day before and we visited nazareth
and tiberius on the sea of galilee
it's quite something to think that
you're in the area where
2 000 years ago this
humble
preacher
inspired a religion which now has over a
billion adherents or believers in the
world a religion based on compassion and
humility
um sometimes qualities that we seem to
have lost
our belief in these days if you follow
politics
and um
we then drove from galilee up into the
hills
zaf da i think it was fd and other towns
and
learned about the crusaders and the
various arab
you know chieftains who ruled in
different parts here
i went over to akri down through haifa
stopped to swim again at uh
netanyahu uh lots of building here it's
amazing the amount of new construction
it's on the language learning front uh
i'm i have been trying to focus on
hebrew while here
big thing for me is to get to where i
can comfortably read the language i'm
still not there yet
uh i can read it when i'm reading on
link because i can i've read the story
before i can click on the text to speech
if i see a billboard and the characters
are in any way stylized i'm lost
but i know that as i continue to read
and listen i'm listen i'm forging new
neural networks in my brain that in time
i will get there
uh you know i think 3000 known words is
a is a number i noticed with greek that
at 3 000 known words i could start to
feel a little more comfortable i'm now
at 7 000 known words in greek
uh i've saved i don't know 17 18 000
links in greek i'm going back to my
greek i want to get my known words in
greek uh up over at least ten thousand
i'm going to have an opportunity to use
uh greek when i'm on crete and in athens
then of course i come back to israel
so i think
hebrew i'm a long way off but i am
encouraged uh i think i've made steps in
the direction of learning semitic
languages so that uh arabic thereafter
will be a little easier i don't know if
i'll stay with hebrew or move on to
arabic one other thing in this area here
last night or the night before rather i
met with
two very enthusiastic israeli language
learners and a girl
who is spanish but of chinese parents
and we talked about language learning
and and i noticed and
we were talking about whether this one
learner who's very advanced in chinese
could afford to leave chinese to learn
another language but he loses chinese
and it made me realize that i speak
chinese today much much better than i
spoke it 45 years ago
when i had just finished my intensive
course when i was translating when i was
interpreting for canadian businessmen
going into china i was using it a lot
but i speak it better today why because
i have learned other languages never
underestimate the extent to which all of
your language learning uh activities are
creating
capabilities in your brain networks for
the language you're learning and also a
greater flexibility and a greater
ability to learn language languages
period you just have to stay the course
sure you can vary and i've done this
with hebrew and i'm doing it with greek
you vary it to the extent that you know
i have a colloquial hebrew so i look up
some explanations of the grammar quickly
forget them and so it's fun to do that
and then of course i want to go back to
my reading and listening which is where
i'm really
forging these new uh neural networks
doing the same in greek you just have to
stay the course and you have to trust
that what you are doing is building up
your capability not only in the language
you're learning but also you're
strengthening your ability to learn
languages period so keep listening and
reading and creating links
and that's all for now the next video
will be from somewhere in greece
probably from the island of crete bye
for now
[Music]
you